did you guys see the mall santa that i
mean this is a conspiracy but did you
see the mall santa
that the kid asked for a nerf gun yeah
and he said santa doesn't bring guns
what a douchebag yeah he like just
brought his
into it he's like yeah yeah all elves
lives matter
so yeah
see if you can see if you can hear this
audio
okay so he's asking for his a little bit
it's a covet santa so there's like a big
plate of plexiglass between the kid and
santa
nice
nope no guns nope
not even a nerf gun oh
yeah i mean what a just [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] it you're not really bringing him a
toy you [ __ ]
yeah yeah like it's not you're a guy
you're not santa
and he says if your dad wants to bring
it to you he can
but you know i don't i don't i don't i
don't bring any kind of guns to the
house and it's like what do you
what a [ __ ] car this is why
but this is why i don't know if i was
meant to have a son
because in that situation i would this
is sparta kick the [ __ ] plexi glass
barrier
and then beat santa to death in front of
a bunch of frightened kids
just say yes because you're not really
bringing the kid a gift
you're you're a fem pretending to be a
fictional person you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you're also getting
fifteen dollars an hour to just yeah yes
you're awesome
keep it going [ __ ] face yeah right let
his mom
work out the gun thing with him that's
not your job virtue signaling [ __ ]
just say yes whatever he wants i want
this i want that i want to raise her i
want to cut myself here you go
enjoy yeah yeah santa can do that
remember to go laterally
[Laughter]
yeah if your mom says okay and you're a
good boy then we'll see
boom you got out of it beautifully not
like no no santa doesn't do that
yeah i i don't know that i would go full
on this is sparta and drop kick him just
because i'm not uh i don't i don't know
that i have that physical aggression in
me the way uh like mike you have like uh
you still have roid rage kind of left in
you
yeah whereas i don't i don't bother rage
so
i feel like i would i would probably
because i was sitting there like
because i the rage started to i felt the
rage that i would feel as a parent like
who are you to try to step in you
fake santa claus and i feel like all you
could do
is i kind of look at him and go wait
ladies and gentlemen
this is not the real thing
this man isn't a bastard it is uh
it is better than i guess it's not
better but it would be funny to see him
the other way around just like
so alt-right or whatever the kid asks
for a gun he's like you want a nerf gun
how about a real one [ __ ]
like all right santa will attach a bump
stock to whatever nerf gun you got
yeah by the way 40 magazine ar
i did hear the end of this story travis
uh yeah in illinois mall
uh he resigned after this viral video
and uh the mall sent the real santa
to the kids house monday with a nerf gun
that he asked for and posted a video
showing the new santa presenting with a
with the uh wrapped gift from the north
pole
and then there's also the part of me
that goes enough already with this
[ __ ] story
like all right this santa's a [ __ ] and
hopefully he's still drunk driving but
do we really need to have someone show
up
during a pandemic and bring the kid a
nerf gun while people are losing their
homes
gives them all right like i would this
is wrong what that santa did
he suck the kid doesn't he doesn't
deserve a make-a-wish
we're not talking about his parents are
still going to be there for him he'll be
fine
yeah he probably forgot about it he was
blacked out
i wish i wish the mom was just like oh
sorry son santa's just a lib [ __ ] soy
boy let's keep going let's go to the
next mall
by the way that guy doesn't resign he
quits there's a huge difference when
you're the ceo
you resign you give no when you're a
[ __ ] mall santa fruit you quit
they're like you got to get out of here
he's like can i resign they'll like go
home
and then they're like they told him to
leave because people would beat him up
right yeah it's another resignation if
your boss flicks a cigarette at you
because the guy's just a dick you
everyone can see exactly what he's doing
and he thinks he's being virtuous but
it's like no the parents right there
they'll work that out that's not your
job [ __ ] and you're not really
bringing him a toy if you were bringing
him a toy you got the right to not give
him something
you're pretending to be something so
[ __ ] your ideas